[Musique]
non
ça a été par hasard à la chose et du
basket est comme ça ça m'est tombé
dessus sur les vélos en fait je faisais
des tests sur un wattbike au creps d'aix
en provence en tant que basketteuses et
j'ai fait des tests assez impressionnant
et arrivé jusqu'aux oreilles de
l'entraîneur de 10,6 mon premier titre
de championne d'europe à glasgow
parce que ça a été mon premier titre
important chez les élites je pense que
enfin voila c'était une émotion
extraordinaire il y avait ma famille je
n'en revenais pas
[Musique]
les jeux bas après berlin on verra par
et 2024 c'est encore très très loin mais
bien sûr on est très content que ce soit
ici